oh thank you remind me of a question
that I've asked a number of people what
do you think about if the inspection
zone right before you go into the
Octagon where the where the the
officials putting the Vaseline on your
face what if the inspection Zone
you were standing on a scale to reveal
how much weight you had put back on
since official weigh-ins the day of
Prior I would love that I would get a
kick out of that but would you love that
as a Fighter fighting I wouldn't mind it
as a fighter I would just say like as a
fan that's interesting to me when guys
will put that size back on that's really
interesting and some guys you'd be
stunned where some guy's Minds goes like
here let me give you an example Daniel
Cormier was getting ready to fight Steve
miocic the second time he finds out that
yes uh that was Rumble Johnson but
Daniel knocks out Stipe they're gonna do
a rematch Stipe shows up he was 248 for
the first fight Stipe shows up at 2 31
for the second fight he like went vegan
and nobody could figure out what the
hell was going on I mean it moved the
line people tore their tickets up but
when word gets out to Daniel that Stipe
is going to weigh in at 231 Daniel goes
and cuts weight so Daniel's coming in
about 250 which puts him at 25 pounds
under the weight limit he didn't for
whatever reason that I do not understand
to this day he did not want the weight
scale to be that lopsided So Daniel goes
and gets in the Saun and pulls out as
much weight as he can to get closer to
stipe's weight which is a weird thing to
do
but I'm just saying that that that's the
point if guys had to get on the scale
they would do weird things that you know
numbers don't lie it makes guys behave
in a very odd Way Daniel being 25 pounds
underweight and going to Asana to get
closer to his opponent because there was
a rumor that he was coming in like
that's weird but he did it but he did it
he's a normal guy and he did it so those
numbers man they make people do weird
stuff
that'd be a kick if they got in right
before the yeah right right there and of
all the people I've asked I asked DC uh
Bruce Buffer asked first like like
nobody's with me on that sure it's you
and me I think they're not with you in
the terms of are you gonna get a
commission to sanction that and actually
do it would it be interesting from an
audience perspective yes it's
fascinating well guys weigh on Fight
Night is is very fascinating how much I
mean what's the most extreme you've ever
seen somebody blow up after a weight
like uh you know how much weight they
put back on 20 pounds oh for sure yeah
there's been 85 Pounders that have
weighed uh 207 the next day you know 185
one day and 207 but I gotta remind you
this is back when IVs were allowed so
you know you go to your room and get
iveed and get get rehydrated and you
know some of that 15 and 20 pounds would
come uh really quickly and easily they
don't do that now so you know you're
close why can't you do IVs uh 12 to 15.
they they banned them a great way to
flush illegal drugs is to then just run
an IV so if you were to take performance
enhancers this was the Lance Armstrong
method then hook up to an IV and flush
that through your system then the
testing agents can come and you'll
you'll be clear so USANA to get ahead of
that just banned IVs
it's like drinking a gallon of water
before you take a drug test maybe but
that never works you know people always
like you know the drinking the vinegar
juice before a drug test I got I got
caught with taking a drug test in high
school with uh pee in my pocket out of
the old apple juice things and the lady
was like what's that I'm like what's
what and she's like ding ding ding I'm
like a [__] I'm sorry
no no it was just like one of those
Martinelli's apple juice okay you know
they look like an apple yeah and I peed
in it and I took it into a drug test
sure no I go it's your own pizza because
my buddy's pee that I was sitting there
all right and I was trying to get a job
at PetSmart cleaning fish tanks nice and
I failed the drug test I'm sorry about
that yeah
drug test
when I was 19 years old that I was gonna
have to take and so I'd like drank a
gallon of water and uh fell asleep my
friend soap and peed on the sofa because
I drank too much water like you put a
pube in the thing and it contaminates
the test you can't take it is that like
uh one other thing about uh that I'd
like to see
um we're watching the UFC fights without
fail every time till the tape you know
introducing the fighter we see the odds
going into the fight you know we know
the the oddsmakers favor
um sometimes it's actually pretty rare
going into a round two or around three
they'll show the live odds and how the
odds have fluctuated since the beginning
of the fight
I would like to see as a rule the
beginning of every subsequent round all
the time show the live odds and how they
fluctuate sure I I just want to know
that that's the closest thing we get to
open scoring and uh not that I'm saying
open scoring is great but as a fan I'm
always very interested to see the odds
and and I'm even more interested to see
how they're changing during the fight I
think that's interesting too I I enjoyed
watching the uh the last presidential
election but they were showing that like
as the states were coming in the odds
were moving all over but that changed it
I mean it does change something as a fan
numbers don't lie so anytime you can get
those numbers like what you're
suggesting it does add to it what do you
think of open score by the way
uh there's an argument that place right
there's an argument that you get people
coasting through fights it makes fights
more boring sure you know
um better to you always want your
cornermen to tell you that you are
losing sure sure and to have official
knowledge that you are not losing is not
good for the fans yeah I agree with that
and there is a massive excitement at the
end of the night when you don't know and
Bruce Buffer makes the announcement it's
a deal and you would be taking that away
and I know a lot of commissions are
looking at doing that Damon's got Coker
against it and I think that that should
be the final say not commissions not
athletes not any but the promoters who
have to find a way to make this
profitable are saying this hurts the
product don't do it I think that they
really need the respect needs to be
shown and so far it has been but it
would change it I mean there is
something that is is compelling about
that I think that showing live odds as a
rule is the compromise that makes
everybody happy sure they do it anyway
sometimes so you can't argue about uh
whether you can do it or not yeah do
they do it in any other sports
um you know in other sports betting odds
are a little bit taboo to acknowledge
like you'll never see it in football
that's right when you were fighting were
you looking at your odds I was not but
that's an interesting point that you
make yeah they don't really do that in
football we got in front of it I think
that they'll catch up but you're right
about that uh no I never was now not
when you were actually in there but I
was so exhausted in there it is such a
tiring sport I came from wrestling you
know you worked every single day just to
be able to go six minutes with another
guy and hold up he's going hard near
going hard then you get into this and
it's 25 minutes I mean it was just it
was so tiring I only bring that up
because you asked if I was looking at
the odds I wanted to know where to look
and if I saw him I wouldn't know what
they meant like you it is in such a a
zone of Every Breath You know every
drink of water just trying to to get
another beat I would have been able to
calculate it if I looked up and saw one
I know what it meant I gotta go deal
with this guy it was different a resume
you're trying to score points that in a
fight the guy's trying to damage you
it's it's different there's nowhere to
stall there's no no way to eat up clock
in a fight yeah very different very
nerve-wracking in that in that regard
do you like shopping on Amazon I do and
good news is Stevo's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon and if
you want a real bundle of a deal you can
get Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
plus Stephen's butthole destroyer and
Stevo's butt wipes for your butthole
it's the butthole bundle available on
Amazon right now
yeah dude